far from the epicenter
but the terrifying power just the same
[Music]
this is Tibet from the other side of the
Himalayan earthquake zone the Chinese
army moved quickly to medevac and treat
the injured when it happened my house
toppled within the blink of an eye we
lost everything in a minute then the
soldiers came to save us it's been three
days since the 7.8 magnitude quake
struck and on the other side of the
Himalayas in Nepal the desperate search
for survivors is still the number one
priority
trapped on the rubble in collapsed
buildings there's still every chance of
finding more people then the possibility
of some life took them as I have we have
seen in Bangladesh after something days
one life victim is estimated from the
there are rescue teams from all over the
world lending their expertise and there
are successes broken and bruised but
still breathing for now the survivors
vital signs are quite stable we just
checked him over and gave him first aid
his leg was trapped for a long time so
we gave him intravenous fluids and
oxygen but the clock is ticking and as
the hours turn into days these miracles
will become rarer even now there are
people who've been found but still can't
be reached they've been working
throughout the night and there's still a
live body in a very dangerous position
it's a collapsed structure you've got
you know collapsing buildings both sides
but they've gone in about approximately
15 to 20 feet down then contact with the
person who's buried there this upper
part of the body is moving so they've
got great hopes as well and that they
are confident that they'll be able to
take him out but when there are no
survivors the rescue turns to recovery
Nepal's leaders say the number of dead
will double to more than 10,000
and with sites like this it's easy to
understand why these funeral pyres part
of the mass cremations taking place
across the country in accordance with
Nepal's Hindu tradition the immediate
focus has been on Kathmandu but that is
slowly beginning to change entire
hillside communities have been wiped out
cut off by landslides isolated and in
need of urgent help rescue teams are
beginning to get to some of these places
[Music]
like here in Gorka the epicenter of the
quake helicopters the only way in
and the only way to get the injured out
for treatment but resources are limited
getting around to everyone will take
time some it will be too late it's not
just villages who are being helped by
these helicopter sorties trekkers Kosan
landslides are being plucked to safety I
was hanging there someplace just to have
the rocks going over me and then he said
you have to come and he brought me to a
place just a little bit outside of all
the rocks were coming down according to
the Nepalese government more than 8,000
people have been injured most have
suffered crush and trauma injuries
[Music]
number of Rises then it could be a
problem that we would be suffering from
lack of bed just immediate post
operatively hospitals and medical
centers overwhelmed at the beginning of
the emergency have now been bolstered by
the arrival of international teams
bringing with them much-needed skills
and supplies even after four days there
are people are still coming to the
hospital now there's a lot of crack
bones fractures and open wounds after
four days without any medical treatment
abilities what they are
the international community's response
has been swift aid has been gathered and
sent from all over the world food
shelter water and medicines are all now
making their way into Nepal a series of
aftershocks
[Music]
Britain has pledged 1/8 package worth 5
million pounds and delivering some of
this a team of British engineers Gurkha
soldiers returning home to help their
fellow countrymen rebuild their lives
and the aid can't come soon enough the
displaced homeless and hungry are many
we have been supporting them this
morning with drinking water there are 16
camps here in Kathmandu Valley and we
try to support it with drinking water
but also toilets hygiene kits and these
kind of stuff we will also think about
food the spring season is one of the
busiest for Nepal's tourist industry
hundreds of thousands of travelers
descend on this small nation to track
her hills and climb her mountains and
many are now only just making it back to
the capital airlifted to safety with
horrific tales of what they've witnessed
two days ago afternoon violent earth
earthquake cliffs come down this come
down four or five quarters deceased
buried in the rock fall
we've been there until just an hour ago
the trails are destroyed a lot of the
trails are destroyed people are stuck
they can't get out it's very bad the
ground is shaking and here's why this is
what they faced on the Himalayas these
Everest Mountaineers since something is
wrong and then a few terrifying seconds
they realize i n't wall of snow ice and
rock crashes into their himalayan
Basecamp still alive sheltering under a
jacket and trying to take in Walt has
just happened the avalanche spreads
panic and confusion
this orientated climbers scramble
desperate to search for their teammates
they have no idea if there are more
landslides to follow but know that they
must account quickly for any missing
people the camp has been wiped out some
climbers have been killed and others
have been injured I told the group to
get down [ __ ] stuff it was like 4,000
feet of snow just kind of covered and
there's no word of Rudd so I told
everybody get down and then I put my
heads over my head like just bury myself
as much as I could basically snow hit
it's about 45 seconds here a minute for
it to go by all our tents were gone and
then like people were pushed like a guy
with who stood in front of me was that
30 feet over there and we were missing
one person that we don't know what she's
alive or dead there were more than 800
people at different altitudes on the
mountain when the quake triggered the
Avalanche some 150 had been stranded for
two days before helicopter flights could
resume and return them to safety we saw
huge pieces of rock and ice coming down
from faces of mikado right over there
over cam 2 yesterday we saw some more
some more ice coming down from her but
it was okay the close call which we had
was with the ice which broke down from
here and it all came down it were just
that we seemed to be in a sweet spot and
luckily nobody was injured
all is shaking my friend Quinta was down
and I was
by last meet many of Nepal's ancient
temples may have been destroyed but that
won't stop prayers being offered her
desperate people can only hope someone
is listening